Cesar Garcia and his wife Claudia have
lived in this home in the desert town of
Coachella California for more than 13
years they've raised three kids there
and Claudia runs an at-home daycare out
of the house but three years ago they
made a mistake that could cost them
their home and livelihood when
converting their back porch into a TV
room they neglected to get a building
permit from the city you know the person
I hire you know they did the courts only
we know premia from the city of
Coachella Garcia ignored early warnings
from the city then a team of inspectors
showed up unannounced he pleaded guilty
in court paid a $900 fine and demolished
the structure as ordered by the judge
then he got the proper permit before
rebuilding and upgrading it into a room
for the daycare he thought the issue was
resolved but six months later a bill
arrived for $26,000 as the local
newspaper the desert Sun first reported
the city of Coachella is holding Garcia
responsible for paying the cost of his
own prosecution the city had hired the
private law firm silver and right to
prosecute Garcia the firm promised the
city that its work would be cost neutral
or even revenue-producing Garcia who
works as a grocery store manager about
an hour and a half from his home isn't
the only building code violator to
receive an unexpected bill
six months after Ramona Morales paid a
$250 fine because one of her tenants was
illegally housing chickens silver and
right into foster for $5,600 a woman in
the neighboring town of Indio who was
cited for putting up illegal Halloween
decorations was charged $2,600 and
another family received a bill for
$18,500 after pleading guilty to having
a broken garage door and an overgrown
lawn as of November 2017 silver and
Wright had collected more than 122
thousand dollars in code enforcement
fees from dozens of residents in an area
in which the median annual household
income is about $36,000 after Garcia
received his bill he appealed that drove
it up another five grand
since Garcia couldn't afford to pay
twenty one thousand dollars in
prosecutors fees within a month
the city put a lien on this house was
like you gotta love your house because
you're not paying 31,000 my house is
where I live for the way we feel safety
here silver and right has a business
model that's premise don't cost recovery
they go around to these cities and they
say hey we can get you ninety percent of
your fees or a hundred percent of your
fees back Jeffrey Redfern is an attorney
with a nonprofit institute for justice
which has filed a class-action lawsuit
on behalf of Garcia and others charged
with the cost of their own prosecution
this is appealing to the cities because
they figured hey if they can do this
work for free that's great the problem
is that once the law firm took over they
have an incentive to prosecute cases in
a complicated and expensive manner so as
to drive up the fees that they can
collect from the defendants callahan and
blaine is known and respected as one of
the leading insurance law firms in the
nation attorney Edward sue silic is
representing silver and right in the
lawsuit when situations like this arise
the taxpayers of the city have to pay
for this it's absolutely a fair outcome
because otherwise who pays that twenty
six thousand dollars it's the good
citizens of the city the lawsuit claims
that the financial arrangement violates
both the Due Process Clause of the 14th
amendment to the US Constitution and the
California state constitution which
guarantee the right to a neutral
prosecutor without financial or personal
stake in the case whether we're talking
about civil asset forfeiture or fines
and fees or you know this kind of
outsourcing to a private law firm it's
all really the same thing
we call it policing for profit it's
turning the criminal justice system into
a tool for raising revenue that is a
naive and false description this is a
city attorney silver knight working to
prosecute laws for the city they
prosecuted over 150 people for code
violations Newson abatement newson
abatement they made the city a safe and
healthy place to live
Garcia and the other plaintiffs allege
that silver and Wright waited six months
before billing them because after six
months they were no longer allowed to
withdraw their guilty pleas which limits
their ability to protest the fees is
that an intentional strategy on behalf
of silvering right absolutely not
was he ever informed when he was
pleading guilty that he was going to
have to pay them tens of thousands of
dollars of legal fees for his own
prosecution well it is certainly my
understanding that the people when they
plead guilty they have the senton that
they have this knowledge and will depose
him thoroughly on this issue any
criminal defendant it's presumed that
they know the law I mean it's not
incumbent upon the police or the judge
or the prosecutor or the city to tell a
criminal defendant what the laws are so
what does the law say about charging
plaintiffs for their own prosecution
Garcia and the other plaintiffs alleged
that silver and Wright aggressively
pushed city officials to change the law
to allow just that for silver and Wright
was hired there wasn't an ordinance on
the books allowing for cost recovery in
these nuisance cases the cities put
these ordinances on the books because
silver and Wright asked them to do so
one partner at silver and Wright is also
a vice president of the California
Association of code enforcement officers
a lobbying organization that works on
this issue
helping municipalities rewrite their
administrative codes is that a conflict
of interest
well first thought they don't profit
from the prosecution in the laws okay
they are they are city attorneys who
work for the cities they're told they
paid for that work correct they do many
many different tasks and
responsibilities for these cities
they're it's called a city attorney you
handle many different functions and
you're paid by the hour in some ways we
have a perfect storm for abuse right now
we have a huge number of very vague laws
lots of them criminal prosecutors who
have almost total discretion to decide
how to enforce these laws they can go
after almost anyone they want if they're
really motivated that they could find
things wrong with my house or your house
you have the people with that discretion
over very big broad laws who have an
interest in getting your money at the
very least those people should be
neutral outrage over Garcia's story led
to the passage of a new law in
California prohibiting cities from
charging defendants for their own
criminal prosecution but it doesn't
retro actively absolve Garcia of his
debt and the lawsuit is also moving
forward to set a legal precedent that
will make other state courts less likely
to tolerate this practice if we win this
case I think it'll go a long ways
towards establishing standards of
prosecutorial neutrality the people who
started writing these codes never
imagined that they would be giving
discretion to enforce them to people who
would then make money off of them as for
Garcia he says the entire ordeal has put
his family's life on hold I still worry
about losing about how because it's
tough it's not done it is you know we
are still thinking about you know those
31,000
[Music]